hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil 3
don't be confused this is not Resident
Evil 2 lo and behold we are in the
police department but it's not Resident
Evil 2 I just need to make sure area
does look clear but not clear of items
definitely need to make sure there's
nothing here for Leon just yet I don't
remember there being a barricade there
before but there are bullets which is
awfully nice also the lion statue is
covered up awfully convenient that they
didn't want me to do the puzzle before
anyone else got here ok I get it there's
definitely nothing at the end of this
hallway I am wasting mine and everyone
else's time we're here for bard yep
there's no reason to come down here I
really wasted mine and everyone's time
ok I'm gonna go through this normal
fricken door don't mind me woah the hell
isn't well let me read about it first ID
card security protocols each member of
the force has been issued an ID card
from now on the same card will be
required to access all storage boxes do
not lend your card Danny wanted to take
great air and using it if your card goes
missing reported immediately hey I got a
card free leave me to do dog give me
what it yes please I'm gonna try to save
my assault rifle ammo until I get
something that's worth blamming and
until I get something worth blam and I'm
not gonna worry too much about
[Music]
hey it's the dude the dude who got his
face ripped off what was that thing by
the way was that the Lichter I do
remember there being a link type monster
oh my that's how you got there wow
that's that is brutal
well I know you don't fall here alright
good good good to know
good to know you do is a weird [ __ ]
door it's the garage win hey come on
here we go ha ha ha this gun is way
better alright so I can't go in there
now whatever you say man
whatever you say oh well that was
definitely a Lichter er Wow hey I'm just
gonna go for it hi I shouldn't have gone
for it well I thought I heard steps
now my here in step sir is that flappy
flaps in the wind you dad you guys dad
good well that didn't sound like someone
was dead
goodbye thank you for playing
caboose key mm-hmm anything I can steal
in here any goodies second take and not
leave for Leon anything that I can put
in my pockets okay oh I can't even go up
through the oh I can't go up there yet
hey I remember having those hey who's
that if you're human speak now forever
hold your peace your zombie please eat
this bullet it's probably definitely a
friend out there there prop Jill yeah
Jill no I had to shoot Jill in the face
I feel bad but not that bad
no wonder Leon didn't get any assault
rifle anything I took all the ammo you
copy
see ap now is that the code before or is
this new code maybe new code yeah use
the lock you dumbass Oh peekaboo I
dodged I thought I dodged didn't I dodge
okay I am doing horribly all right you
can open hey what's up hey how's it
going ha
goes the weasel all right big gun damn I
was just not hitting you hey man you
climb up high bud
Wow yeah get out of here do you think
I'm afraid of you man Leon better thank
me for clearing out a lot of these
zombies he would have had a much rougher
time if I was not here the hero of the
hour there another one in there I think
one of them was still alive the hero of
the hour who's also taking all the
supplies wait wait wait this should be
one and this should be two and this
should be three and that should be for
anyone who does anything otherwise is a
Neanderthal Oh
oh really I should probably just go for
center of mass with this thing there's
no way I'm gonna be able to pop heads as
easily as I would with the pistol so
might as well just do center of mass the
recoil will hit it higher as need be
locked
[Music]
you think I waited on my goody gracious
oh my good golly my oh hey
oh you did oh you're not dead
your head is basically gone alright at
least now I can be accurate with this
thing oh god what was the code Oh what
was the code to this thing oh man
what was the code I bet if I remembered
it from the first game I would be able
to open this I'm willing to bet cuz I
don't think that changed I don't think
that was a random code that was static
damn I don't remember I'm sure it says
somewhere in here but nah damn it god
damn it Rodney gray unlawful creation
and or possession of explosives fun I
didn't do it for me I did it for you why
doesn't anyone understand the corpses
attack from the shadows okay buddy that
storms coming where this umbrella is no
good gotta blow it up or you'll be more
than just wet yeah gotta get more bombs
yeah they're coming soon got a hurry
burn them burn the corpses burned them
good during questioning the suspect
began to shake violently before resuming
a shrieking fit questioning was ended
and I said that if administered whatever
you say buddy do this sub sex suspects
unstable psychiatric condition suspects
testimony changed from the moment a
moment delirium explosive collected
battery was moved safety deposit room
who there's a bomb in the bathroom also
I gotta check something real quick I
literally I'm stopping by
cuz licks ian is playing Resident Evil
right now and I just wanted to stop by
give them a super sticker and then I
gotta get back to recording so I just
took a little break to pre slick seeing
everyone pre slick seein these dreams
games sometimes over on lick seeing TV
if you haven't subscribed Alec seen
these amazing genius that edits like the
majority of my videos so if you haven't
subscribed to him or giving him some
thanks lately just go ahead and do it
there's a reason why the videos are
edited so well and it's all him okay
cool but back to the game okay where
were we where was we I know I know the
'i'm welcome Leon Leon
I wonder I'll look it up real quick and
I want to see
okay so 9:15 7:15 oh [ __ ] it's the same
Oh
get screwed Leon Leon you suck it's the
same code
oh wait a dick Leon eat a dick all right
I got it yeah Leon you'll never get that
Oh Leon you suck you suck dong whose
song and I do not so tough focus for you
buddy who's there was it what your duns
oh and just for good measure who just
did that you'll get back up no I see no
yeah that's right that's how we do and
looks like he's down for the count
yeah kind of [ __ ] up well there's
zombies now so you gotta do what you
gotta do safe room well that was an
ominous sound for safe room anyway just
fine internal memo office supply
relocation heat-resistant three number
content safe ah I would have gotten it
right there I hadn't looked up but it
was the same as the something evil to
which i think is like kind of cool when
you think about it it's so cool that
these stories are interweaved like this
it's all happening at the same time all
happening at the same with cameras kill
those things I'd be sent
did I get a Cameron flux can't remember
film contains evidence do not leave out
it says you screw you says you eat a
douche well why is the music so dramatic
what was that what did I just do oh it
sound like a shoulder charge what well
it's it's not so much a dodge there's
like a shoulder charge can I bust a
shoulder can I boss all over these
zombies that will be nice I'm gonna try
that I'm gonna try that copy that
all right well it is up ahead but at the
same time there's an up B stairs he over
here and I really want to give that a go
you did didn't you don't get up yes stay
down
[ __ ] stay down oh my god it's effective
stay down [ __ ] stay down damn
who needs ammo who needs it not me not
me baby not me walkie that's the
evidence storage locker
you're not even real ooh was it CDP I
just saw it damn what was it oh [ __ ] I
just saw it it was written it was
written god damn it it was least the
knife doesn't run out this time a whole
knife durability thing in the last game
was real stupid okay I'll be right back
I'm gonna go find out what it was
Wow baby baby I'm back I'm on a roll I'm
back baby baby I'm back I'm out of
control back baby
I'll shoulder check you I'll check you
in the next yesterday huh [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what I thought [ __ ] oh don't be
so dramatic
hey you ain't got no skin why am I
worried about you
no skin off me talk about no skin off
you cuz you got none see ap governor see
ap ah my photographic memory betrayed me
see ap see ap I see a P what was that oh
never mind
DCM whoa hey shoulder check ah that did
not work okay so if can't shoulder check
you too good
stay down stop resisting and you're done
you're done you're done you're done
you're done okay that's nice that is
nice that's yeah I gotta tell ya hey but
oh I feel like I haven't been looking
for those at all hey there's nothing in
there what's the deal what a ripoff ooh
looks like I might have been got hmm
weird oh well 109 106 104 fun-fun-fun
109 this is why all these were empty
because I stole them yeah all right yes
I'll take a grenade come to Papa come to
Big E baby yes indeedy-do died is mine
now yay ah West officer still something
in here
what could possibly still be in here Oh
lockers didn't even notice that got
everything okay cool all right let me
just go to stop by the thingamabob it
for the thing of Moby ray no no no yeah
down stay down no no no no no no stay
down no not stay down
no no Stata whoop stick stick no stay
down there we go okay now I gotta stop
by here you're distracting me from my
cause all the things I gotta do let's
stick with this in there and this in
there and combine these combined
let's save the grenade for a rainy day
okay all that roundabout I got let's
still go up to the third floor and do
the thing with the locker I hope there's
something good there better not be a
grenade because they've literally just
put that away and if I have to put away
another grenade I'm gonna be very upset
with myself and everybody around me so
everybody better watch out because I'm
about to be upset if I get another
grenade I don't know why be upset if I
get another grenade specifically but I'm
going to be rather peeved this iam
that's fine with me that's good enough
for me I'm not gonna be angry and nobody
with that that's good stuff across the
board 100% good stuff everyone loves
that especially biggie all right let's
do this
where are we going be on the lookout for
horrible monstrosity they want to rip
out your teeth note to a friend if
you're reading this I'm already dead if
you heard any noise coming from the
locker do not open it please
wow I wish I would have read that note
in the first game I focused on finding a
way to get to the other side I realized
that explosive might be our best bet I
mean I should rig up a pretty good bomb
but we don't have any batteries for the
detonator I'm pretty sure I sent one of
the safety deposit room we need that
battery if we're gonna knock this wall
down I hope I don't need to spell out
why you must not open the locker please
don't worry about me just get yourself
out of it that's again don't worry about
that 600 I lent you then give it a gift
for your upcoming move Oh as soon as I
left the shower so you were you were
nakey I washed through it as best I
could but I feel worse and worse so
who's in the locker better not all right
what about this one is c.a.p Hey
flashbang good because I only have that
all right so there's a bomb oh there is
a bomb
there's a bomb well I hope there's a
timer on this bomber this is gonna be a
short trip fun missing a battery you say
oh that's is not a lot of time I find
three is that three minutes or three
seconds
Oh three seconds yeah it's not far
enough okay the shock wave would have
blasted your eardrums right off your
hinges well that explains that oh stop
in the name of the law oh sorry I got
steamed Oh guys and fast okay so for
this thing I do got a hit headshots Wow
you bastard you a-hole there's so many
of you were taking showers God how many
was it shower cloud explain while the
police officers were bit down yeah it
sucks to be handsome sucks to be popular
handsome suave good-looking all of the
above with so many of you well now
there's less of you stop being obtuse a
shoulder up shoulder check you I'll do
it oh that's less fun who the hell from
whence you came good thing I shoulder
checked on the way over can you not get
in here here's the other thing
it thinks you can't get in here awfully
convenient for me no no
no you're dead no mmm so sad mm too bad
mmm so sad too bad yeah well I'm getting
plenty of assault rifle Emma I don't
know why I was being conservative about
it
oh well something else in this hallway
probably another Lichter more like lick
turd am i right he got him probably
already said that before about then the
only other thing
all right bard Marty boy Marty boo Barta
Barta
Barney bar dö ardougne Oh
Oh dr. Bart Oh God Oh how I'm not trying
to reach somebody don't worry we're
gonna get you out of there just tell me
where you are I'm trapped in a goddamn
hospital surrounded by every kind of
abomination look just send in Stars
they're gonna know what to do now
negative our PDS overrun - then figure
it out I'm brother's gone crazy they're
killing all the researchers I only one
who knows how to make the vaccine to
stop this on these so you can either sit
there with your dick in your hand or
sent send somebody who's capable of
getting me the hell out of here okay Wow
yeah yell at the hell already yeah you
would you heard what he said we can't
turn them over to the company
that's not our call to make that's no
hyo's call I'm gonna check the computer
see if I can trace the docks location
yeah not our call to make but look did
you run into anything on the way over
here am I the only one anything useful
okay but you know did you did you have
to use your gun at all or was it just me
the whole time did I feel like I was the
only one that went through hell just to
get to where we are now maybe I even
cleared the path for you rejected the
mansion Internet this bizarre incident
occurred in a mansion owned by the
umbrella corporation located in the
Arklay mountains July 23rd Stars Bravo
team was in spatch to the Arklay
mountains to investigate series of
mysterious and grisly murders
interesting interesting interesting
casualties were numerous the only
survivors were five minutes of stars the
cause of the incident was the illegal
bio weapon experiments being carried out
in the secret of rubella lab beneath the
mansion the t-virus being used in these
experiments escaped the facility and is
presumed to be the root cause of what
all that occurred however all evidence
was destroyed along with the mansion so
further investigation has proven to be
an extremely difficult hi Jill hello man
stars it was way above the pay grade of
a police beep-boop that seems important
if I remember correctly it was important
Oh bee-boop indeedy beep ooh what do we
got more I am a man why did they lock up
all their assault rifle ammo like this
seems awfully negligent well no actually
it's the opposite of negligent it's over
a cautious all right how many more
things are there a save point a medkit
nothing for Leon go to hell we on Oh
that's everything buddy let's uh let's
roll out let's get out of here you got
the docks location or not okay good no
I'm out of here
yeah what's up
derailed was anyone hurt Joe [ __ ] wait
what Joe Joe what happened
Jill come in
see I gotta go do what you gotta take
care of bar
[ __ ] really that's when a Windows
Update is gonna happen right in the
middle of a cutscene Oh play the game
jails in trouble we're gonna go into Oh
feels fine okay cool fine how's your
ribs they're good your ribs okay was
breathes deep if it hurts it's a problem
with your ribs whoa all right what do I
have here what do I have here is this
all my goodies did you put everything in
the right place is this everything I had
better than no no that other guy
definitely made it he's got
self-preservation instincts
I can't wait to shoot him I remember
doing one of these doors specifically to
keep out an Emma SUSE if I got an a
Masucci crawling down my ass I'm gonna
be very upset Carly big news limp Nicks
and I've got some new weaponry for you
that's guaranteed to put the brass back
in your sax
they're called mine rounds these babies
were developed by umbrellas military R&D
and they will light fires even hotter
than the lover you left back home
they're tough to find and tricky to
handle but trust me they're worth it
look at the specs yeah don't get cute
and try to load them in anything else or
I mean walls the ground they'll stay
right where you put them sensor in the
mind direct enemies okay
the landmine all right fine by me
landmine cool I'm not gonna use them I
would never use them you told me it was
a limited resource the last thing I'm
gonna do is use them you kidding me yeah
out of your mind of course I'm not gonna
use it I will take the grenades though
with this way they're perfect
that's a good-looking inventory all
right let's see where our adventure
takes us
nanananana yeah yeah yeah oh my god hit
him alright shoot gun time
alright shout gun time
oh she was already going down I wish is
a shotgun shell on her not getting a lot
of bullets around here oh hey how many
of you have I missed
pride plenty probably a whole lot
definitely too many i man there's a lot
of you it's almost like they wanted me
to use the the mines oh well I got
grenades for that no you stay down
[Applause]
alright fine
what step oh you're not gonna stab well
there's no point in knife life is
useless there we go
I've popped them good like a balloon
good thing I'm immune right right guys
right everybody right good thing I'm
immune it completely mune MU any immune
[Music]
well how are you alive after a direct
blast from a buttload of c4 that's
pretty impressive you know you can't
help but be impressed
alright there's goodies here oh yeah
bullets just laying on the side of a
bench
seems like Raccoon City to me st.
Michael's clock tower is a baroque-style
building which stands at the heart of
Raccoon City and has become a beloved
icon and residents consider it to be
emblematic of the city as a whole
hollow to the car filled with corruption
boozing pus exactly like Raccoon City
st. Michael's Church erected this hour
in 1908 with the assistance of several
philanthropists it was dedicated to the
children born in developing city and the
first floor was used as an elementary
school for many years the city saw
further growth during its
electrification over the course of the
early 20th century and the zoo
body of st. Michael's elementary swelled
over 600 students unfortunately st.
Michael's elementary was shuttered in
1978 is beginning building the MCL wear
and tear the clock was deactivated in
strict limitations were placed on the
entry around the surrounding premises
years passed with this one's beloved
monument in the public plaza on lockdown
but in 1980s the umbrella corporation
worked in league with Mayor Michael
Warren to renovate and reopen the area
this time with proper preservation
efforts in place the clock tower was
officially reopened in 1993 and today
the sound of its heavy tolling bells can
once again be heard throughout Raccoon
City
I'm sure there's nothing nefarious about
that
definitely no nefarious plots or
undermined efforts there no way in hell
would that be the case there's something
else around here everyone keep your
peepers peeled ah methinks you think so
I must have missed so many of those I
think of my problem is I'm looking at
the map too much instead of looking
around because I bet if I wasn't relying
on going to the map all the time being
like there's red here I would have seen
everything in one of those but I didn't
so I can't regret anything and I'm good
here you mad oh he's a little grumpy Gus
what a [ __ ] Carlos respond yeah we
didn't make it the train derailed
everybody's dead mihail everybody
nicolai left us to die you're bigger
whoa what the hell what the hell it's so
big I'm strong what the hell job am i
doing anything game I've been playing I
don't even know I can't even talk push
it forward and I'm whoa nice dodge Jill
that thing is awesome
how'd you get so big what did you eat
what's your workout regimen
Wow it's in boss battle time because I
do not have well I do not have the
necessary I don't even have my grenade
launcher my dude dude I neglected I made
a few errors by the by just so you know
Yipes I don't know what I'm going to get
but I'm getting it okay
oh crap okay combine their I don't have
what you're asking me to have my dude
mom and my main squeeze well that's not
good
oh okay life I thought that was for sure
des oh all right
your mistake was letting me get back up
you fool okay way he missed me now you
have to kiss me and by me I mean that's
Grenada missed me kisses I will beat you
with a fist
oh no I won't no I won't the answer is
no I won't yippee I do not like you Sam
I am I do not like you green eggs ham
did you open that box for me thank you
oh that doesn't seem good that seems
like a church oh whoa did I get that I
think I did perfectly time I just got a
Dark Souls this [ __ ] whoa missed me
you would never want to kiss me thing is
I gotta be patient I can't do too early
or else I'll get blow stood it's okay
it's okay
Wow too early now it's too early too
early definitely on the too early front
of things oh wow man you so loud my what
the big lungs you have am I supposed to
do something is there some like
environmental trick okay oh my god oh my
god oh my god where what are you doing
yeah kinda what are you doing what's the
story what are you doing yeah I feel
like Oh
how what in what what about what cool
thing am I about to do am I about to do
something cool I bet I am
oh I dodged that perfectly do they
Oh barely got it apparently you're about
to take a nasty fall what does that mean
okay yeah I know I know I know I'm
looking I'm looking I'm looking I'm
looking I'm seeing I'm seeing I'm seeing
the truth I'm seeing the the answer the
answer is in front of me the answer is
in the heart of the cards the answers in
the heart of my cards the heart of my
cards cards of my heart I don't see the
answer I don't know the answer
I will knife you on a knife you [ __ ]
don't think I won't whoa I dodged are
you going buddy
I don't am I supposed to know oh this is
where a mine would come in handy this is
where mines would be very handy right
okay game but what what if what if I
don't what you're asking me to have yeah
how about that
nice spin real cool stuff how we look I
don't I don't know what you offered me
my dude I literally the thing you want
me to do I do not have uh-huh all right
here we go
knife time time time baby oh my god I
got you [ __ ] oh my god oh [ __ ] dude
I've got a chance
oh my god you're gonna get brackets you
can't get rekt by me with it is a knife
that's right run a scamper scamper you
need um scampering boom scampering yeah
yeah watch this I must stop you with a
knife knife [ __ ] I don't have any
healthy I do I do I feel good I feel
good yeah okay yeah go yeah try how
about you Frick
I got you come on you freak break yeah
got you oh that's the wrong way
wait a second wait I don't have that God
my God if I don't have my guy I'm a dude
I didn't know nice
this knife really are you dead for good
I think you must be right here you want
to shove some mine rounds inside you
[ __ ] yeah yeah that seemed like a good
idea
yep
okay funny I didn't have enough ammo
left
Oh
Oh that can't be good
hi
you've done me a big thing
you're welcome
well we can all be friends roughly half
a day later chill
hey cancer me demon Tyrell do you copy
what's going on Jill's been infected I
I'm taking her to the hospital
maybe dr. Barton Seaver alright uh yeah
right by the neck you hang in there
super cop I got you all right well then
thanks for being there for me big breach
on that one
fight it Joe
I'm gonna get you the vaccine I don't
know if it's a matter of fighting me
okay I promise I don't know if there's
much of a choice wait what am i doing oh
I need to okay I see I see what's going
I was like what the hell am i giving her
like a little medicine to kick her off
with maybe I spray this open your eyes
but you're gonna be fine it's secure
herbs you'll love it and that's my
essential oils so unfortunately that's
all the time I got for this one slightly
shorter episode this time around but
don't you worry we're in the hospital
and we are ready to go get Jill that
cure you wait there Jill you wait don't
you worry about thing when you see this
what does it what you see this I don't
get this meme alright so thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to more Resident Evil coming at
you very soon and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]